demain à colmar maintenant au conseil
départemental ici donc on pousse les
murs pour faire de la place
enfin surtout pour l'économiser la place
visite guidée avec le président je vous
montrais un ancien bureau en quelque
sorte traditionnels vous pourrez suivre
les bureaux il a planché sur le sujet
eric straumann ça c'est donc le bureau à
l'ancienne un peu grand quoi vous aviez
le bureau de travail avec une petite
table de travail et vous voyez on peut
installer une cloison la cloison c'est
ça le secret pour multiplier les bureaux
au siège du conseil départemental les
murs on n'épouse pas en fait on les fait
pousser voit la main vers l'enduro ici
pour la transformer en deux bureaux
voyez ce sont des décloisonnements
mobile comme on installe très facilement
et puis on a gagné des espaces de
l'espace pour l'instant et de l'argent
bientôt les premiers bureaux avoir été
réduits ont été ceux des élus pour
l'exemple maintenant ce sera au tour des
fonctionnaires de se serrer tout ça pour
éviter d'avoir à louer des annexes comme
c'est le cas aujourd'hui
l'idée c'est de faire de 270000 euros
d'économie de rapatrier cinquantaine de
postes de travail ici au double à
l'hôtel du département des gens
travailleront main dans des surfaces
plus petites
tout en sachant que cela ne va pas
affecter les conditions de travail du
personnel et celle du président
d'ailleurs puisque ce petit bureau de 12
mètres carrés c'est le bureau d'accueil
du président bon il a aussi gardé le
grand mais aujourd'hui il n'avait pas
trop envie de nous le montrer
bon c'est jamie il reste encore un peu
de place l'art sur la terrasse de la
façade